hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand final of the magnus carlson chess
tour uh it's the armageddon game between
magnus and ding
and it was a it was a really wild match
like we said the
semi-finals are the best of five but the
finals is a best of seven
and uh here uh it all started by ding
winning the first game then magnus
retaliated in the second one
the game we've shown then the two games
ended in a draw so that's it for the
rapid games
then we had two blitz games uh one which
was won by ding and then
magnus one on demand and then we have
the armageddon so in the armageddon
magnus carlsen chose white
so he um has a minute more on the clock
but he has to win and if ding is able to
draw then ding wins the first match so
let's see
what magnus chooses for the armageddon
game and how it how it goes so here we
have
d for by magnus knight to f6 knight to
f3
g6 and again bishop to f4 magnus goes
for the for the london system
we have bishop to g7 and e3 now
being just castles we have bishop to e2
and the d6 so
all all seen before we have h3 and c5
referring to capturing the center we
have knight b to d2
as magnus usually does prepares c3 the
knight can be shifted to b3 if the queen
goes after the b2 pawn
and c captures on d4 we have e captures
and
knight to c6 we have c3
strengthening the center and now e5 by
ding the carson's king is still in the
center of the board so it does make
sense to open up the position
so d captures e cap d captures on e5
and bishop to g5 ding now goes after the
bishop
now h6 and here magnus trades we have
bishop captures on f6
queen captures and finally magnus
castles and now
uh the material on the board is
completely equal being still with the
bishop
bear and here no one moves uh in this
position are bishop
to f5 and queen to e7 making room for
for the f5
pawn also guarding that b7 pawn so the
bishop can be developed
but here dean goes for rook to d8 and it
is a new move so already as of move 13
we have a completely new game so let's
see how magnus deals with it he goes
queen to b3 of course you want to get
the queen away from the d1 square you
want to bring your rooks into the game
and put pressure on b7 so it's uh
somewhat difficult to develop the light
square bishop so ding goes back
queen seven uh he guards the upon here
and now prepares bishop to e6 to develop
the the bishop with
tempo so rook eight to d1 and now even
e4 uh threatening the knight
uh threatening knight forcing it to move
and the knight doesn't really have all
that many good squares knights the e1
is an option but it's it's an ugly
square for the knight so magnus decides
to go for knight to h2 but now
uh e3 biting and now it's a problem you
cannot capture because if you capture
queen captures with
check and you lose the knight on d2
so that's uh one way uh so magnus
instead goes knight to d to f3
and now ding captures an f2 so e
captures an f2 with
check rook captures and only now bishop
to e6 nicely continues developing
queen to a4 by magnus and now a6 uh
just uh not allowing that pawn to be a
target after the rook moves also b5 will
be an idea very soon
so rook back to f1 sorry rook to e1
now aligning the rook with the queen
here uh and
now b5 biting we have queen to f4 by
magnus
now saying okay you cannot capture the
pawn because if you capture the pawn i
can capture this pawn as it comes with
the
discovery on your queen and my rook is
nicely defended
so here ding prepares for the capture by
playing queen to c5 now bishop captures
on a2 is a threat
and magnus defends it by going a3 and
knight to e5 by ding ding is very uh
very very happy with his position here
you can see that he's uh his pieces are
much better
developed than carlsen's pieces this
knight is somewhat
weirdly placed on h2 also the rook on f2
not doing all that
great so of course the ding just wants
to trade double rooks and the d file
with rook a7 rook d7 uh and uh
he has a very comfortable game so magnus
goes to bishop f1
and the ding trades we have knight
captures knight captures and rook to a7
ding proceeds to double up rooks
on the d-file and now knight to d2
magnus starts re-maneuvering that knight
to e4 and then hopefully to f6
uh to force a trade of this very strong
bishop for the knight so rook eight to
d7 ding doubles up
and knights the e for now comes with an
attack on the queen and also
knight to f6 is coming ending allows it
he goes
queen to b6 he doesn't go queen to e7
and now magnus goes for the knight f6
check we have check
captures and capture so now it's a good
thing that the queen is on b6 guarding
the bishop
white could have some ideas maybe of
going queen arrow rook captures followed
by captures and captures
but this way with the queen here you
don't have to worry about anything so
here
rook to d2 by ding now with a double
attack on the rook here
saying that i'm very happy to trade a
trade off even more pieces
but here magnus goes queen to f4 putting
uh
pressure on the rook now the rook is
attacked twice although not really
since this rook is pinned but also
putting pressure on the
h6 pawn uh and okay with ideas of maybe
going this rook here
uh which wouldn't be all that great but
you know you have to
you have to reduce some of the tension
but this queen to f4 move
uh isn't all that great as dink here has
a very
very very nice move so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this nice move for ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
and sorry about the knocking my my
neighbors are uh you know re
redoing the the house so uh i hear some
knocking i don't know if you guys
hear some knocking uh but yeah for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that
the rook is indeed pinned and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook capture sun b2 so just
eliminate the base of the pawn chain now
these two become weak and of course you
cannot capture as the rook is pinned
like we mentioned
so here the thread is now rook coming to
d2 with a triple attack on this
rook so magnus quickly goes rookie three
now the queen no longer pins the f2 rook
and now
rook captures here is a threat but uh
now dink captures first
we have rook captures on f2 queen
captures and now king to g7 not allowing
the queen to come to f6
and now ding is up a pawn and he has a
very very comfortable position and
remember ding is very happy with the
draw here if he draws the game he wins
the match magnus needs to win this game
so here magnus goes for queen to e1
but now this only allows dink to further
advance his advantage so once again feel
free to pause the video and
find a winning move for ding while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
quickest way to victory and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
remember the rook on e3 is still pinned
so just uh deflect the queen
rook to d1 and this is indeed what ding
played
uh so queen captures and d1 you don't
have to capture it but if you if you
move the queen then
you don't really gain all that much and
then black just goes after the pawns
so here magnus did capture being
captured with check we have king h2 and
now queen captures on c3 now ding is up
two pawns
and it's uh it's going to be very hard
uh if those those pawns start uh
marching down the board so here we have
queen the d6 by magnus
defending the pawn threatening this pawn
uh but the ding says no problem
bishop to c4 offers to trade down even
even further so bishop captures b
captures now ding created a past
c pawn and the queen captures an a6 he
doesn't mind giving up one pawn because
now he has
queen to e5 check and this position is
completely winning for black but
the both of them are minute and
something on the clock and you don't
really
and there is no increment in armageddon
so you don't want to overstay or welcome
so ding
instead of going for the win he just
forces uh a perpetual here with queen to
e5
check magnus goes king to g1 there isn't
uh anything better and now you see you
can simply
uh continue con not like that but you
can simply continue checking uh on the
on the dark squares here which is what
being does queen e1 check king h2 queen
to e5
check uh if you play g3 it doesn't
really matter you can just continue
checking with the dark squares queen b2
check and then just continue
wherever uh so king g1 we have queen to
e1 check king h2 queen to e5 check
and it was in this position that the
players
agreed to a draw uh or rather it is a
draw
by rule of threefold repetition
so uh really really exciting match but
in the end
uh dingleran takes uh match uh match one
away from carlson and it's uh it's very
nice that uh this time his connection uh
pulled through
as uh in some previous competitions his
internet connection was constantly
uh giving out and he was constantly
losing points uh
due to uh disconnect disconnection
issues
uh but here uh no such thing happened i
think it happened one during the match
but it didn't really pose all that
much problems uh i'm not sure though
because i didn't watch the entire
coverage
uh alive uh but yeah there you have it
the
the london has fallen and even though
carlson's london system
pretty much always prevails regardless
of who the opponent is
here in this instance it didn't so yeah
that's uh the game i hope you enjoyed it
and the entire match it's
now 1-0 for ding in matches
uh i would like to thank andrew wilson
michael salviani galan murray
ariel's facey and giron [ __ ] for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
final checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your monday